[Music]  thank you for joining us for the opening  ceremony for the 2017 sim field top as  well as tinned a designer chest  challenge a real honor to be here  tonight I feel very at home as a former  fashion model myself it's funny  the fashion district in st. Louis used  to be the second largest in the nation  and we're thrilled to have the st. Louis  fashion fund located right next door  thank you to the chest campus for  collaborating on this incredible design  challenge each team was made up of when  st. Louis Fashion Incubator designer and  one chess grandmaster now I don't know  which dress is going to win but I do  want to say to all of our grandmasters  playing in this tournament you will not  have to wear it the winner of the pin  design challenge is Audra  [Music]